hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast
I'm your host Sean Carroll in today's
episode we're gonna tackle a perennial
big question in the Natural Sciences
trying to understand the sense in which
the world is complicated now I mean this
in a very particular way I mean there's
a way the world could be which is
completely chaotic right like things
just happening at random there's no
order or structure anywhere there's
another way the world could be which is
completely rigid and orderly right the
actual world is somewhere in between
these two things there's sort of poles
of chaos and order and we balance
ourselves in between that's one feature
but the other is no one planned it right
there's a lot of central designer that
says this is how things should be this
the universe somehow organizes itself
and when I say the universe especially
of course here on earth in the biosphere
so today's guest is actually a
mathematician Steven Strogatz has become
very well known for his popular books on
mathematics but he's equally successful
as a researcher as I mentioned in the
podcast he's the author of a paper that
has well over 30,000 citations which
makes regular physicists like me very
jealous and one of the founders of both
the field of studying synchronization
spontaneous synchronisation of different
physical systems and then out of that
study came the study of networks and in
particular small world networks the way
that many systems like the human brain
or the internet or organized where it is
neither just you talk to your nearest
neighbors nor you talk to everybody but
again somewhere in between how does this
sort of mixture of chaos and order
naturally come about through the working
out of math and it's equations so Steve
is a wonderful communicator and a real
pioneer in this field so I think you're
gonna enjoy this conversation let's go
[Music]
Steven Strogatz welcome to the mindscape
podcast
thanks very much Sean I mean you are
very well known as a popularizer of math
but you also you're extremely well known
as a doer of math I tend to think of the
math you do as almost kind of physics
it's not that you know the pure math
that is a proving esoteric things you're
really hands dirty there in the real
world I mean how did you come to think
of yourself as an applied mathematician
what did that that's not something that
most people grow up wanting to be mm-hmm
that's a good point and I didn't even
know it existed when I was in college I
thought I wanted to be a math major and
they had a Wizkid linear algebra class
for you know the people who had done
very well in math and high school so I
found myself in there and I got crushed
in my first semester of college got the
worst grade that I ever got in college
in that course and it was um you know
was the kind of course that is supposed
to be a like to weed out the people who
don't have the right stuff to be a pure
mathematician there yeah they were
trying to decide who who's gonna be the
mathematician of the future and
otherwise people because a lot of kids
in high school think they're pretty good
in math and the idea was correct them
very early on some I have to say to this
day I still resent that course because
they put a really quite weak teacher in
there and so it was a real sink or swim
experience for all of us and I
definitely was taking in a lot of water
this would this would be a big deviation
from the plan of the podcast but that's
okay ivy actually I'll say that my best
podcasts have involved deviations from
the plan but let me just remark that we
live in a culture in physics and in math
of this weed them out sink or swim
let's do ask them to do impossible
things and see who suffers the least and
I personally think that that is not
really the way to make the best
scientists or mathematicians me well of
course I agree with you you know as a
weed or it would be we'd almost weeded
out I mean I think we lose a lot of
talent with that kind of approach and
there's no need to be that discouraging
so yeah I mean I
do kind of want to go along on this
thread um because it's something a lot
of people have experienced this feeling
of having once loved some subject and
then getting discouraged in college and
it's not necessarily a bad thing if you
you know long as it turns out okay you
go in some other direction so in my case
I thought well maybe maybe I really
meant to do physics and so to respond to
your earlier question I took a lot of
physics too which was always a great
interest of mine but it was love the
idea I love the idea that physics is
where you went by after being weeded out
because that is not how physicist ik of
themselves come on I'm not saying I'm
not saying that math was my thing
because I didn't feel like I had
certainly I was a disaster in the lab I
knew that already from high school and I
I felt like I could my physical
intuition never seemed especially great
I don't know especially like Freebody
diagrams for things pushing on even
action and reaction I always found that
very mysterious so it is don't feel bad
yeah
but the math part of it when at once it
was converted to equations then I felt
very secure so I thought that was my
natural strength but then I started to
think otherwise after this one very
proof oriented course and I had never
really had any experience with trying to
do rigorous math proofs at that point in
my life so anyway I enjoyed the physics
course especially enjoyed sophomore or
sorry it was the spring semester of my
freshman year we took a course we I
think because these other kids that were
in the same cohort out of the
electricity and magnetism book by
Purcell I know I know that you would
know that book and maybe some of your
listeners will know that book that's one
of the most beautifully written
textbooks in any subject I would say I
think do you agree with that yeah no we
didn't use it when I was undergraduate
but I I know it since that it's very
very good I mean what was so interesting
to me about it was that it didn't just
tell you for instance that the force
between two charges is going to be along
the line between the charges it lets
suppose it's the electrostatic force
there's how much does a proton pull on
an electron you know that that's going
to be some force and in high school I
had learned this thing coulombs
that the force would go along that line
between her but what was so interesting
to me and Purcell is that he said that
follows from the symmetry of space but
that's not just a property of this force
that's a property about space because if
you imagine those two particles by
themselves in an empty universe
otherwise empty there would be no
assuming that space is the same in all
directions there is no other preferred
direction than this line between them so
it has to be along that line and whether
you believe that argument or not I just
was entranced by the idea that you could
you could make an argument like that
yeah you can see how this would light up
the mathematician inside you so anyway
I've taken a big long detour from your
original question but I the point was
that I always liked math but I did like
the math of the real world or at least
the sort of semi real world that we
study in classes like physics class not
the real real world where I had to you
know catch my clothes on fire make
sparks in the lab or something I mean I
studied cosmology and in quantum
mechanics I I can't make any claims to
being too involved with the real real
world but it's applied maths an
interesting field right I mean in I
guess pure math is the alternative it's
really about proofs right you know
here's somebody's we're gonna prove some
things
there's also physicists math which is
this wonderful growing field where we
say things we think are true and we give
some arguments for them but we don't
actually prove things and I think
applied math I have the feeling is
somehow in between those poles well it
means many different things to many
different people so some some see
applied math as I mean just to be clear
since we haven't really said about these
things there are these two roughly
speaking two flavors of math so there's
math that looks inward at itself which
is what I think of as pure math and
there's math that looks outward at the
world at the world very broadly
construed it could be oceanography it
could be the universe it could be
biology whatever but it's it's a math in
the service of something else or
sometimes it's math inspired by
something else you know like something
beautiful that happens in physics can be
then the beginning of a new mathematical
theory and
some people would still call that pure
math but I would think of that as part
of applied math or maybe close to what
you just called the physicist math or do
you actually in your daily in your work
in your papers are you typically proving
a theorem or you know I noticed that one
of the wonderful things about your work
is it very often you sort of figure out
what the answer to the question is by
doing some computer simulation that's
true yeah I'm a no-holds-barred style
I've really you know I've definitely
been called a physicist by many of my
mathematician friends but that they see
me as using the spirit of physics and I
do from the physics culture that I
absorbed I learned that it's you know
that that you should try lots of
different things you can guess you can
use intuition you can use physical
reasoning you could use computers you
could do all kinds of different
sometimes a proof is great if you can do
a proof but it's not the only game in
town whereas in pure math that is the
the end all and be all is to prove
theorems I never never know so I'm
definitely not one of those for me it's
um
there's all kinds of ways of getting
evidence and trying to understand what's
true I'm definitely interested in the
truth about the equations or the
mathematical models that I study but um
I sort of actually feel a lot of
infinity affinity with artists I must
say this this could take us in an
interesting direction I bet you have
yeah I mean from some of your writing
although we never met I get the feeling
you'll resonate with this but I I'm
really interested in something that you
maybe you could call like mathematical
Impressionism that is instead of making
a photorealistic painting of the world
or the mathematical equivalent I I'd
like to get inspired by something in
nature or in the world and then do
something that's much simpler that's
that's the essence of what's out there
sort of like the way the impressionist
painters didn't try to capture the
details they weren't interested in that
they were trying to with their either
their dots or their bold strokes convey
the heart of whatever that was and so I
I like my models to be for instance II
there was one paper that I did with my
colleague Renny Morell
mathematician at Boston College where we
were thinking about a certain problem
but it reminded us of a fireflies that
all flash in sync you know all flashing
on and off together and what we did was
not an accurate model of real fireflies
I would never claim that and we were
careful in the discussion at the end of
the paper to explain why fireflies were
quite different from what we were
pretending in this paper yet they were
somehow like the essence of what the
fireflies were doing so yeah and that's
that I mean to a physicist that just
makes perfect sense I mean it's
obviously there's math involved but the
idea of distilling down some complicated
thing to the simplest possible
description that captures something
vital about it is what we do for a
living in our own minds uh-huh
so I've always liked that attitude in
physics and I do feel it has a lot in
common with an artistic impulse and yeah
well let's just be clear it's not like
this is something that everyone would
agree with there there are quite a few
applied mathematicians who say that's
not good enough you you should really
try to make a model that that is
testable and the ultimate arbiter is
reality like if your model doesn't do
the right things in experiments or
doesn't match observations even
qualitatively then you've gone too far
you know then you've fought by the
essence so I mean this is I mean I sort
of believe that I agreed that if you've
gone too far of course you have lost the
essence but the truth is if I'm really
being honest about it I care more about
math than nature okay that's a dirty
thing to say but it's okay well that's
right and that's why I'm not a physicist
yeah because I think a physicist
ultimately does care about getting the
science right and there's this evil part
of me that says if it's beautiful but a
little bit wrong I'm okay with that it's
still beautiful
yeah difference between a fine artist
and a photojournalist absolutely right
or an illustrator well maybe so I mean
there's an old kind of making this
flattering conversation for a comparison
from your perspective right I'm I'm the
illustrator you're the fine artist ah
well it's just a matter of what people
are interested in you know so I think as
long
you're honest about what you're trying
to do then I think it should be okay
it's just it's just where you pretend
that something is realistic and it's not
then you're gonna get in trouble and you
know the example you used is perfect
because I wanted a segue into this whole
question of you know get to an example
of what you've been working on for your
whole life I suppose
I guess it's applied mathematician
themes come back and forth rather than
just working on one big problem for your
whole life but the fireflies are the
example that you used in your book sync
to introduce the reader to this
wonderful thing that appears all over
nature in very different forms where you
have independent agents doing something
and yet they naturally fall into
synchronization it was that was that
Firefly paper that you alluded to there
the first example of when you thought
about that phenomenon it's certainly one
of our very earliest I say our because
again that person I mentioned earlier
Ronny Morello I did a lot of this work
with him he was and still is probably my
best friend and we did a lot of this one
we were just starting our career so I
was a postdoc he was a new assistant
professor but anyway yeah it was very
early that was in the early 1990s and to
me it's part of a larger theme a cosmic
theme about order emerging out of
disorder I always found that spooky
almost theological you know because in
physics in the simplest case like say in
thermodynamics classes we learn that
things tend to disorder if you have a
closed system with no energy coming in
or getting out and we do you know then
then the second law tells us that
systems gonna just come to equilibrium
and they'll be disordered sort of
maximally it'll as we you know in the
jargon the entropy will keep increasing
so but yet we see fantastically
organized structures all around us we
see civilization we see you know biology
organizing itself into ecosystems and
living things cells I mean there's it's
in there's this fantastic fight between
the forces that want not want but you
know that make the universe attend to
greater disorder and yet we see all
kinds of what looks like spontaneous
order all around us so that's still
somewhat mysterious from a physics
perspective
although we it's not to say we're
contradicting the second law that's not
possible that's a correct law more or
less I mean we could talk about that but
let's not leave let's not go there no
actually I'm a this is one of my pet
peeves you have not said to anyway Pepys
but there's a pet peeve I have about how
people talk about the second law where
they say what everyone says which is
that in a closed system you tend to
disorder and then they stop and then
they say but look at these open systems
you get order but they can't help but
telling themselves you know the order
appears in this open system despite the
said no no there's no right spite yeah
exactly
there is no despite that's like saying
moon orbits the earth despite the force
of gravity because you think that
gravity pulls things together and the
moon doesn't fall so let's obviously
despite the force of gravity but so I I
just you know react against that no you
didn't do it you're not guilty of it but
I think that there's a lot of work yet
to be done exactly out how open systems
do organize themselves and how entropy
is actually part of the reason why that
happen at SAR not setting again closed
by it sure we're on the same page with
that I mean that's that's the challenge
of non-equilibrium thermodynamics that
it has to somehow be consistent with
what we already know to be true from the
equilibrium or close to equilibrium case
yeah and yet the math is and and and the
conceptualization the physics part of it
they're just very difficult and that's
some of the most exciting research going
on right now in in non-equilibrium
statistical physics so I independently
Firefly's her an example of this well
you know I don't approach it from a
physics perspective because first of all
I never took step back statistical
mechanics I never went that far in
physics so I don't really know what I'm
talking about here but I did work at it
from the perspective of someone
interested in differential equations
which allow us to describe systems that
change in time or in space or both and
you know so something like fireflies you
can make a little abstract version of
them where you think of well what's
going on with a firefly if you have you
have a single Firefly that you're
keeping alive in a jar
you know that you've captured out in
your backyard then it will flash and
then its flash has stopped and then it's
sort of dark for a while and then
somehow is building up its readiness to
flash until it reaches some we don't
know really what's going on but there's
probably something happening in its
nervous system where it's got a little
timer some little circuit knurls I mean
oh think literally it's not known
exactly how the flash rhythm works yeah
that's interesting I was gonna ask is
that we really I don't know obviously
but it's still not even know anything
but I mean we know something about the
chemistry of what the substance is that
that um you know sort of ignites and
flashes we know about the enzymes that
degrade it but I loosely speaking it's a
bit analogous to something we all learn
in first year of physics where there's a
charge between two kaput you know on
capacitor plates that's building up it's
like in the jargon an RC circuit right
or a relaxation oscillator something is
building up toward a threshold and when
it reaches that threshold then you get a
sudden discharge which in this case
would be the Firefly flashing or in the
case of the RC circuit would be the
capacitor dumping its charge and then
starting to build up again as it charges
up so we at Rennie Murillo and I made
this little model of effectively lots of
little relaxation oscillators building
up discharging and every time somebody
discharges it kicks everybody else up a
little bit closer to their firing
threshold or they get excited or
something like that yeah that's right
and it's B and that part we know is
correct qualitatively that fireflies not
only flash but they see the flashes of
others and adjust the timing of their
flash rhythm in response to the flash of
others we know that from experiments
where you can use a pen flashlight to be
in like an artificial Firefly and if you
periodically flash your flashing
flashlight at this Firefly for instance
you can play tricks on you could flash a
little faster than its normal rhythm and
then you'll see that Firefly sort of
scurrying to keep up not literally
moving its feet but it flashes a little
bit faster to get stay in sync with your
abnormally fast flashlight
to limits I mean if you drive it more
than like 20% faster than it wants ago
it can't keep up and then it falls out
of sync this is not helping the
reputation of mad scientist's and
sadistic experimenters on the animal
kingdom they do a lot of worse things
than this well anyway so so we do know
that there are interaction rules that
can be measured through the kind of
experiments I just measured and so the
hypothesis was always that what's
happening in a congregation of fireflies
is they're all both flashing and
receiving flashes from others and
adjusting in accordance with some rules
and so then the big math problem is and
it's something that transcends biology
they're not trained to solve a question
like this if every Firefly is
individually obeying the rules that you
can measure then is it the case that
synchrony will emerge automatically
every time in such a population and that
turns out to be quite a hard math
problem because of the discontinuities
in it that you know I said when there's
a flash then first of all the flash is
like a sudden impulse just a quick on
and then quick off and then also we
imagine that the to continue that that
capacitor analogy that the discharge is
very fast so the Firefly like sort of so
to speak instantly goes back to its
baseline before it starts charging up
again and so yeah joints yeah when you
have jumps in any kind of system that
you're trying to describe with math
unfortunately the apparatus that we use
in math assumes everything is smooth and
continuous and doesn't jump around
discontinuously so but you say yeah when
you say the apparatus I mean this is
these are all human constructions right
like the math where you have to doing is
comfortable with this so this is why you
get paid the big bucks to sort of
generalize that way of thinking a little
bit yeah thank you I didn't mean if
apparatus in a laboratory
I meant the mental tools that we use
specifically I'm avoiding using the word
calculus but that's really what I want
to say that calculus is predicated on
the idea that things can change but they
only change smoothly they don't jump you
know discontinuously from one place to
another whereas these fireflies sort of
act like they do
at least it would be sudden flashes in
the sudden response to flashes and so
what made the problem hard and why it
was a research problem for us was that
you know how do you accommodate
something that is on the one hand
continuously charging up towards its
threshold but then at the same time it
can suddenly flash and suddenly
discharge and go back so is this mixture
of continuity and discontinuity that
made the math abnormal and and weird and
challenging and this is all started by
in a very scientific way in the sense
that we saw the fireflies doing this
this had been known for a long time the
fireflies got into sync somehow and I
guess as a human being your first guess
is that well there's a boss Firefly
there's a yeah your leader that is
telling them what to do there's a
conductor for the orchestra but that
didn't seem to pan out empirically so
your question was could it be
self-organizing this coming in - yes
exactly right right I did get a little
ahead of myself there with talking about
the math it is a great story that you
know people that lived in Thailand or
Malaysia had known about this they've
seen it forever but the first Westerners
to come to those parts of the world like
Sir Francis Drake from England in the
1500s there are ships logs that we can
read of his sailors saying as we go down
these rivers you know like the river to
Thailand there's there these strange
creatures that live in the mangrove
trees that flash and they call them
lightning bugs you know so I could call
them growing up in Philadelphia so you
know it's don't like so many yeah yeah
lightning bugs fire fights whatever you
want to call them date but what was
spectacular is that there would be tree
after tree for miles along the riverbank
filled with these fireflies thousands of
them it seemed and they it soak like you
could visualize it almost like a
Christmas tree with Christmas lights on
it except that these are beetles that
you know we think of they're not they're
these little beetles that have this
strange
flashing property and they the whole
tree will ignite and get dark
simultaneously and it goes on all night
long and it's just an amazing spectacle
so but the question was as you said how
is it possible these
not the most ingenious creatures they're
just fluff you know they're just little
bugs yeah and and at the beginning of
the night they're not doing that when
they fly into the trees you know as the
Sun Goes Down they're totally
disorganized if you if you get there at
dusk you don't see the phenomenon it
builds up over the night and it takes a
while but by the middle of the night
it's perfectly organized so that was
always the question is it that there's
as you say is there some kind of master
Firefly like a conductor for the
orchestra and they're all following the
lead of that one that's not going to be
a very robust biological way of doing it
because if a bird eats that particular
maestro you know what then it's not
going to work that night yeah so who
appoints the the head Firefly that
doesn't it doesn't seem biologically on
the other hand you have to keep in mind
that there are things in biology
organized like that like there is a
queen bee who is a different from the
other bees so it's not unthinkable that
there's a king Firefly but no one ever
found one and so the the prevailing view
today is that that it's done this
spontaneous synchronization is an
emergent phenomenon that it as you say
itself organizes you don't need an
external signal like lightning in the
jungle you don't I mean those were the
old theories that there was you know
look it's in the tropics there's gonna
always be some lightning storms and all
the fireflies get startled by the
lightning flash and that kind of pre
synchronizes them all as they respond in
shock to that lightning bolt but that's
ridiculous because it happens every
night even if it's not raining so anyway
but there were like I say there were it
was a very old problem and it was only
by around the 1960s that those
experiments that I mentioned was pen
flashlights demonstrated that that the
fireflies are both reacting to flashes
as well as emitting them and the
conjecture was always that they somehow
through that process of interaction come
into sync but no biologist could figure
out how to demonstrate that because they
didn't have the computers that could do
I mean it's not the way that they think
they thought of different training so
you really need to
physicist or a mathematician to try to
work on this and the mechanism is just
that the fireflies are looking at each
other and somehow what they see is
affecting their rate of firing that's
right exactly so yeah if they see you
know a flash when they were not
expecting to see one it might tell them
oh god I'm a little bit late and then
not consciously but through just some
unconscious processes in their nervous
system because we don't think of them as
having much consciousness they just
automatically adjust their timing
something in their nervous system
changes in response to seeing this flash
such that on the next time they will be
more nearly in sync with that flash and
it's not an especially complicated form
of order or especially sophisticated but
still it's self-organizing in the sense
that there is no teleology right there's
no goal there was no idea that we're
gonna get together and do this it's just
everyone's doing their own individual
thing and sudden thirst not so suddenly
but y'all ultimately they're all doing
the same thing I saw you you know do the
same thing at a TED talk where you ask
everyone to clap in the audience and
very quickly they're all clapping in
rhythm yeah that's an interesting
comparison because they're the audience
knows it's trying to get in sync and but
but yeah you're right that the fireflies
don't have any particular goal and and
there are different theories about why
they're doing it I mean I should clarify
it's only the male fireflies that are
doing this it's definitely something
going on with mating you know it's not
it's not just all fireflies the females
are flying around and they're looking
for males to mate with and it seems that
well so this is where the biologists
haven't quite figured out what they want
to say they used to say the idea was
that all the fireflies of a certain
species would get in sync because it
would send their message the farthest
possible distance because you would make
a very bright signal that could escape
you know the darkness of the jungle you
could sort of the females could find
them from far away because there'd be
this beacon like here's where all the
boys are you know but still from a
Darwinian perspective how is it to my
advantage if I look just like my
neighbor
you know the Eagles Minh do the females
flash at all
they will flash yeah I mean sometimes
they they will flash they actually do a
little dance of light where they flash
and then if the male is flashing in the
right way that is they want to mate with
someone of the right species because if
you go with the wrong species you could
get eaten yeah okay um but so but they
do they send signals to each other and
you know if the flashing is done in a
way that they find attractive that or
from someone of their species then
they'll actually be drawn toward it so
yeah that the females are flashing to
there's a lot of signaling to find each
other and make sure everybody's on the
same page and your your mathematical
result was it that this kind of
spontaneous ordering by a
synchronization is inevitable or it
happens under the right circumstances is
it rare and fragile or generic or what
well so yeah that's the the particular
model that we made was the simplest
possible thing where we imagine every
Firefly could see every other Firefly
and that isn't really true you know
really they would mostly see the ones
that are near them in a tree and they
wouldn't be paying very much attention
to one that's a mile down the river yeah
but we ignored that so we did what in
physics would be called the infinite
range approximation where every Firefly
is imagined to be able to interact with
everyone else out to infinite distance
away from them the the reason for doing
that is that when you're studying
something that consists of a million
interacting you know complicated they're
they're sort of complicated for the
reasons I said with this are certain
analogy so if you're trying to study the
collective behavior of a million of
these little tricky things you don't
want to think have the additional
complication of who exactly is talking
to who so because we didn't even know
how to solve the simpler problem yes oh
so yeah so in the case that we did with
everyone interacting with everyone we
proved actually this is one of the few
times we did actually really prove a
theorem we proved that for this model
they would always synchronize in the
sense that in the it's not that there
wasn't a possibility of something else
happening it's just that there was zero
chance of it happening so in in the
jargon it's
like this if I what I want to say is it
had probability zero yeah it's not the
same so what's a good analogy for this I
don't know for physicist it's gonna
happen you know you're you're a
mathematician you're trying to be more
careful don't bother it's gonna happen
zero probability doesn't mean that there
aren't possibilities of it happening
it's just that you'd never see them in
practice I mean to give a loose analogy
if I throw a pencil in the air there is
some possibility it could land on it's
point and balance yeah that is possible
it's just you're never gonna see that
that's right I mean it's possible that
the popular vote for president would be
exactly a tie right yeah these things
can happen but your your mathematical
notion of you know measure zero is even
less than that this is just not very
likely so the idea the fireflies are
going to come into synchronization that
was great that was a great triumph and
then but the one of the wonderful things
and one one of the wonderful things
consistently about good math is that it
finds application all over the place so
in the brain in how we sleep and things
like that similar notions come to rise
right mm-hmm that's true there are there
are so many different examples of
spontaneous synchronization that are
important in science and in medicine and
nature so you know like you mentioned
the brain so a lot of neuroscientists
will tell you that synchronous
oscillation of neurons in the brain is
related to phenomena like attention and
memory you can sort of see sometimes
when if you're looking under an fMRI
machine you know that's like people call
them brain scans or they talk about what
part of the brain lights up when
someone's doing a certain task or
whatever very often the way the brain
will sort of get itself ok so here's an
example suppose I'm looking at an apple
you know what that's and I can recognize
that it's an apple you might think
that's kind of obvious of course you can
recognize it but not everyone can
they're people with brain damage who
can't recognize simple objects anymore
so what there's actually a miraculous
thing happening in our brains when we
see an apple on the table and recognize
it as an apple and not something else we
think about what's involved you have
specialized neurons that detect color
there are others that are looking at
shape there are some you know that are
thinking about other qualities of the
Apple and we somehow put all those
different qualities together to
recognize one whole coherent object the
Apple and what you observe in the brain
when that's happening is that the parts
of the brain that are noticing color are
actually firing electrically at the same
frequency as the parts that are noticing
you know shape or whatever so so so
synchronous oscillation is the brains
way of the biologists call it the
binding problem how do you bind all the
different features of an object into a
coherent single object to recognize that
it's not just a bunch of different
things happening in your brain all at
once interesting so it's not just that
there's a part of my brain saying I'm
seeing something red and another part
saying I'm seeing something apple-shaped
but they're saying it in synchrony with
each other and somehow that lets of the
brain or our conscious perception say
that is an apple yeah and it says
exactly those separate things that are
all oscillating and sync are all
meanwhile other parts of the brain that
are not paying attention or that are
thinking about or you know like
interested in other aspects they they're
out of sync and so they're ignored it's
the brains way of telling itself what's
what's all part of one object or one
sensation oh go ahead oh I was just
gonna say I'll be very honest and
confess that I didn't actually read this
chapter of your book I just you know
remember the the chapter titles I wanted
to ask you about it but does this imply
that there's a separate part of the
brain that is keeping track of the
frequency of oscillations to say oh yes
this is a coherent thing hmm that's an
interesting question yeah it might be
I think the thalamus is often regarded
as a relay station for that it takes in
signals from different parts of the
brain and it might do some of the
binding of what's happening elsewhere
right okay I'm not positive I've got
that right so obviously your listeners
correct you know scientists and
physicists so yeah you're allowed to say
that not an expert onion part I'm not
sure but I
I'm pretty confident that if you ask
most brain researchers now they'll tell
you the binding problem is solved by
synchronization well that's the best
current guess now I should say you don't
always want things in sync in your brain
so epilepsy is a famous disease you know
you can picture someone having those
during a seizure the most famous symptom
is these rhythmic convulsions and the
rhythmic twitching and convulsions is
that many millions or billions of
neurons are discharging in perfect step
when they're not supposed to yeah that I
didn't know about does it some problems
and this is this is always one of the
problems with organization that you want
the right amount of it yeah exactly so
yeah you can have pathological synchrony
too and where does sleep come into this
I literally just yesterday was having a
conversation with a bunch of scientists
in different areas about you know so why
do we sleep and you know the answer is
often well there's this chemical that
puts us to sleep whether it's a higher
level question what is the purpose of
falling to sleep is this kind of
research relevant there it could be
that's question wow you know I mean that
takes me back my PhD was about sleep
research I on human sleep and circadian
rhythms those 24-hour rhythms that we
have in hormone fluctuations and body
temperature and lots of other internal
rhythms so you know but nobody has ever
really believe it or not figured out why
we need to sleep it might sound
ridiculous like my mother when I was a
kid say she actually said she had a
theory she said because you have too
much sleepy gas that's what mechanistic
theory I like it yeah she said when
you're awake the longer you're awake the
more sleepy gas you build up and then
eventually when you get so much of it
then you have to go to sleep and then it
goes away so she was actually doing the
RC circuit model that I talked about
earlier where something builds up to a
threshold and then she imagine he gets
integrated and chewed up when you're
asleep but actually that isn't so far
off from what is one of the leading
theories of what's going on is that
there are sleep substances that are
measurable there are yep tides that that
can be detected for instance there's a
classic experiment from a long long time
ago maybe
on the order of a hundred years ago
where researchers kept asleep sorry
sheep the animal the farmyard animal huh
you keep a sheep awake how would you do
that I mean you could probably keep
bothering it and disturbing it and
poking it I don't know if so they did
something to keep the poor sheep awake
for way past its bedtime so let it let
it read Twitter that'll be enough yeah
you can tell me what you could do sleep
deprivation on an animal and then the
experiment was take a little bit of the
blood of that animal that is sleep
deprived and injected into another sheep
and that other sheep falls asleep right
away okay so is that that certainly
seems to imply to my scientific mind
that there is a chemical tracer in the
blood that's saying dude you should go
to sleep yeah that so that and we've
over the years isolated candidates for
that for a long time it was thought to
be something called me Rommel peptide
that was the the alleged sleep substance
I think others have been found since
then so it's possible that that's one of
the things that's happening that just
being awake and active produces
biochemical byproducts of activity that
that give you the subjective sensation
of feeling tired and that that is you
need to restore yourself back to having
less of that stuff so sleep is partly
for that but it seems there's a lot more
going on with sleep I mean there are
ecological reasons to sleep depends on
if you're a predator or prey you know if
you're prey you want to be in your
burrow especially when it's not
favorable for you right here like an
animal that wants to be out in the
daytime then you better be hiding when
it's nighttime when all those nocturnal
animals are looking for food so you can
see how synchronization it gets involved
with all of these different things
certainly I'm about to fly to Europe and
I know that jetlag is something that
hits me very hard and apparently that's
in part because different circadian
rhythms inside your body get out of sync
with each other
mm-hmm they're right exactly that is
what jetlag is it's it's a funny thing a
lot of people get confused about it and
they say I've heard so many people say
oh I don't get jetlag I just you know I
I stay up all night and then I sleep it
off the next day and then I'm
better but what they're what they're not
noticing is that jet lag just is not
only about sleep and sleep disruption
they're all these other rhythms that
were not so aware of that are inside of
us like you know I mean you could if you
think about it you're aware but when do
you want to go the bathroom when do you
feel hungriest when are you most alert
those are internal rhythms and then
there others that like I say body
temperature is going up and down even if
you lie still in bed and people have
done experiments like this just keep
someone awake in bed all day long you
can measure their temperature and is
going up and down like a nice sine wave
so there there are internal rhythms of
temperature of alertness and what
happens during jetlag is that even if
your sleep gets on to the local time
your internal rhythms are still back at
home time that's the lag in jet lag yes
every single person has a lot of things
going on inside them that can be in or
out of synchronization it really does
max right that's right and so the there
are things in the outside world that
help to resynchronize this light it's
most important is sunlight but food is
another one the timing of your meals
will affect and melatonin of course
people have heard now of this brain
hormone melatonin that you can use as a
pill for sleeping pill or for a
circadian rhythm restoration pill but I
have to say I've always been skeptical
of melatonin not having used it so maybe
those of you people out there who are
listening and do use it and swear by it
I'm not saying don't use it but I can
tell you that in experiments picograms
of melatonin are enough to be
biologically active that is that be a
one followed that's like 12 zeros right
you know picogram is a tiny tiny tiny
amount of melatonin has a biological
action so I can't imagine how much is in
a pill I think it's like a trillion
times more than your brain wants so I
feel like really you're taking such an
ungodly amount of melatonin I would be
scared to do it but I don't hear of
anyone having trouble with it so I'm
probably wrong
you know I'll confess I think the
melatonin is a miracle drug for me it it
could be entirely psychosomatic but
because I don't take sleeping pills and
I generally have no trouble sleeping and
even
I take you know nyquil I wake up feeling
groggy and I just don't want to do that
but when I travel and I I want to get to
sleep it's something like the local
bedtime I take melatonin it puts me out
and I feel no after-effects the next day
it's well I gotta start doing it I mean
not this is a case where I'm too much of
a theorist yeah well you know it could
be killing me long-term I don't know but
hope not ya know okay you you you raised
this issue and I was I really wanted to
leap in at the time but I mean we had
other things to talk about so I didn't
do you raise this issue with the
fireflies of the approximation where
every Firefly is seeing every other
Firefly now obviously that's not true
but maybe it's a good enough
approximation to get what's going on in
something like the brain it's even
obviously less true and it's kind of
super important that it's not true right
every neuron is not talking to every
other neuron and I I think correct me if
I'm wrong that this kind of
consideration led you to think about the
phenomenon of networks and how things
were connected which eventually resulted
in a paper that has so many citations of
my jealousy is overwhelmed well it is
that's right the it was it was a desire
to move away from that very unrealistic
infinite range approximation and to just
start paying attention to whatever new
phenomenon would occur if we if we tried
to be a bit more realistic about the
networks that really do occur in so many
different phenomena that that got us
thinking about what came to be called
small world networks so the phrase small
world is supposed to make you think of
that experience that we all have when we
get on a plane or go to a cocktail party
and you meet somebody and you start
talking and then you realize oh yeah my
cousin went to that summer camp and you
know so then people say oh it's a small
world because it seems like how is that
possible we how can we be so or there's
also the counterpart you know the other
phrase that you hear all the time is six
degrees of separation yeah that I know
someone who knows someone and we can
connect ourselves to anybody it seems
through just a very small number of
mutual acquaintances
or chain of acquaintances well already
came a popular game right that Kevan
brighting game with with actors I'll
mention that this morning Jennifer my
wife is a science journalist said do you
know a guy named Erik Winfrey and of
course yes because he's a professor at
Caltech but also I realized you know he
I think is the nephew of one of your
collaborators or mentors in the in the
synchronization game right he's actually
the son oh he's the son oh yeah he's our
twin freeze son and our twin free was my
closest mentor of my career world yeah
it's a smaller one I went to work with
art Winfrey he at that time he had a 12
or 10 year old son Erik who has gone on
to be a great scientist and as your
colleague at Caltech but who also I'm
notable about the two of them is that
they're one of the few father and son
double MacArthur Award winners they both
got MacArthur prizes that's something to
tell your dad like I got my own
MacArthur now yeah so two geniuses in
the family but and Eric was very smart
little boy I'm not surprised he's turned
out to be a very smart professor too and
it's actually not surprising because
we're all academics and scientists and
so forth but if you did a very simple
view of the world where everyone knew
you know whoever lived within five miles
of them and nobody else then it would
take a huge number of steps of
separation for me to get from someone in
another continent and the small world
network phenomena says no it's it's
really just not like that at all yeah
that's right that's that's what's so
counterintuitive because we do have this
strong sensation that I only know the
people that live near me geographically
or that are in my department at work or
you know go to my church or whatever it
is so we feel like we move in small
circles and so that's why we are always
so surprised and say oh wow that's weird
it's a small world and yet you know if
we were statistically minded we should
be thinking this small world thing keeps
happening to me it must not be that rare
right because everybody experiences it
so it's it there must be some
explanation and one of the things that
Duncan Watts who was my grad student at
the time was interested in his father
said to him do you know that you're only
six handshakes from the president you
know you could find some Pete you may
not have ever met let's say in this case
Donald Trump but you might know someone
who knows someone and within six
handshakes you you'd know someone who
knows Trump yeah so that that struck
Duncan as an interesting thing because
at the time he was trying to study not
fire flies but crickets you know there
are crickets that can chirp in unison
it's the analog of the fireflies
flashing in unison so the biologists
speak of choruses of crickets that are
all chirping at the same time and we
have us particularly she's of those
crickets snowy tree crickets as they're
called that live in Ithaca and so we
thought we could do experiments on these
crickets and see if some of the
mathematical models of synchronization
actually predict what the crickets are
really doing that would be new because
the case of the fireflies in Thailand
much harder to go all the way to
Thailand and capture them but the
crickets are right here in the orchards
in Ithaca New York where I you know I I
teach at Cornell and so we F we have
masked like the grand master of sonic
synchronization right here s noe tree
crickets so we thought that would make a
nice experiment for Duncan to do for his
a project for his PhD work and so he
learned how to capture the crickets and
keep him alive and we were starting to
put them in little soundproof boxes so
that they could we could control how
strongly they could hear each other and
you know like sort of try to set up an
experiment with the help of a bio
acoustics expert named Tim forest anyway
it was in the course of doing these
cricket experiments that Duncan started
to think about I wonder you know when
the crickets are out there in the
orchard who's actually listening to who
do they all hear each other that can't
be right maybe they only hear the ones
right next to them and so he got to
thinking about connectivity in general
and then he threw a brainstorm has
remembered this thing his dad had said
about six handshakes from the President
and so he came into my office one day
and said I well how would if things were
connected in this small world or six
degrees of separation way would they
synchronize better than if they were
just connected to their neighbors or
would they I mean how would how would it
work
mmm-hmm and I thought oh I don't know I
mean I don't even know how you do this
six degrees thing what and so we realize
there's a whole big math problem what
explains the small world and not only
that but how would it affect
synchronization and Duncan said it's
much bigger than synchronization it
would because anything that's connected
like that well you'd think it would make
a big difference because everyone is so
close to everyone in the sense of the
small world
just a few hops away from everyone else
so like how would that affect diseases
spreading yeah at the time actually
people were talking about HIV a lot you
know it doesn't get discussed as much
anymore but during the height of the
AIDS epidemic you would hear people say
if you sleep with someone you're not
just sleeping with them you're sleeping
with everyone that they slept with and
everyone that that person slept with so
the idea was out there that you know you
feel like you're only interacting with a
low-risk group but actually you're only
a few steps away from from you know from
the virus let's say I think I'd actually
like I would like to try explaining
these two concepts that you talked about
in the book that are that are relevant
to characterizing these networks the
idea of the shortest path between two
people in the network and the separate
idea of the clustering right like how
many people are connected to overlapping
friends mm-hmm terms totally yeah it's
it's not not very hard the idea of of
path length is just the idea that we
were talking about with six degrees that
if I mean like let's say you and I we've
never actually shaken hands right so we
haven't met but and I don't actually
know what our shortest path is but we
could start naming physicists and
mathematicians that we've met like I
okay I'm gonna guess I'm guessing you've
shaken Brian Greene's hand I have he's
been a previous podcast guest so okay so
and I know Brian Greene because I've
known him since he was a high school
student so so that would make and I
don't think there's any faster route I
mean I
that's one handshake from me - Brian and
one handshake from him to you so we're
two degrees of separation apart and
that's our short as possible yeah that's
our path length right so path length is
just what's the shortest route from one
node
network to another and you know so okay
so that's one thing you can calculate
for a network you look at all the
shortest paths between any pair of
points in the network and then that
average is what we would call the
average path length in the network which
is basically a way of quantifying this
idea that everyone's about the number
six is not important it's just that it's
a small number of steps from any point
to any other point even in a very big
network like something the size of the
world with seven billion people but but
if your network were more like a lattice
where you only knew your nearest
neighbors then the average path length
could be enormous that's right so right
if you picture a checkerboard like think
of the nodes in the network as being the
squares of a checkerboard honest a
literally a checkerboard which is eight
by eight if you wanted to go from one
corner to the diagonally opposite corner
the fastest way you could get there well
you could go down the diagonal I guess
but that would still be eight squares in
between yeah and so there if the world
starts getting big that shortest path is
also getting very big it would not be
you know like in a world if it were
seven was it well seven billions sort of
hard to take the square root but if it's
five okay so let's say yeah so let's say
was if it was ten to the tenth so if we
had ten billion people on earth which we
will pretty soon before ten billion
people on earth and they were standing
in this big square checkerboard pattern
that would then be as you said ten to
the fifth so that's a hundred thousand
people on each side of the square
hundred thousand series of separations
and I would say six degrees of
separation I'd say a hundred thousand
degrees of separation and the one would
say it's a small world cuz it wouldn't
be right so the point being that that
worlds don't have to be small the the
checkerboard world is not small and yet
our world is small so so that was a
question that Duncan and I wondered
about what does it take to make a world
small the other question though is you
know the common sense answer to this
what does it take to make the world
small comes from an old idea that like
suppose I have a I know 100 people or
whatever number you want to pick it
could be a thousand
but say it's a hundred you know like I
know them well enough that they could
they would lend me money right you know
maybe I have a hundred close friends and
contacts and relatives okay so if I know
a hundred people and each of them knows
a hundred people then night naively I
can just figure out how small the world
is by saying a hundred times a hundred
or in your scientific notation that the
10 to the 2 times 10 to the 2 that's 10
to the 4th and if I want to get to 10 to
the 10th I have to do this 5 times so
you know it'd be 5 degrees of separation
if the world were such that I know 100
people and everyone else knows 100
people except not the same hundred
people not even drank in other words if
there's no overlap then this simple
multiplication of a hundred times itself
doing that five times that will be
enough but that's the trick as you say
there the problem is that of the hundred
people I know when they know 100 people
a lot of those are the same people
because we live near each other or
because we're in the same profession or
whatever and so that's the pro that's
what we're calling clustering the fact
that it's not just a random choice of a
hundred people anywhere on earth but so
we have a more precise definition of
clustering which is we imagine you could
think of it this way think of two people
you know and now ask do they know each
other now maybe they do like maybe they
do or maybe they don't like maybe
someone you're thinking of right now is
someone you went to high school with and
someone else is somebody that you know
now from work and they've never met and
they don't know each other okay so those
two people don't know each other even
though they both know you but you could
also think of two of the people at work
maybe they do know each other so the the
concept we had for clustering is pick
any two of your friends and ask what's
the probability that they're also
friends of each other yeah okay so it's
an it's a number from 0 to 1 and in some
types of worlds that number will be very
small and close to 0 and in other types
of worlds it would be very also we used
expressions like we imagined kind of
fraternity world
we're or you know the only people you
know are the people in your fraternity
so of course two of your friends will
know each other because they're in the
fraternity too right
okay so that in that kind of world the
clustering coefficient as we called it
will be very close to one it's almost a
certainty that your friends will know
each other whereas if you picked your
hundred friends at random on the surface
of the earth you know for me there's one
in Ethiopia and one in Indonesia and
then each of them pick their friends at
random hundred friends somewhere else on
earth there's very little chance that
two friends of yours would know each
other that just the dots are way against
it that they would happen to happen you
know there's no reason they'd pick out
of their hundred people out of ten
billion
why would they pick those same friends
and these two examples would be sort of
like the classic kinds of networks that
people had been thinking about either
everyone knows everybody else so there's
lots of clustering and the path is also
also very short or nobody knows every
anybody else and so the path can be
short but there's no clustering is that
right well let's see if we got that
right I mean I think I didn't get it
right I think not quite so the like the
checkerboard world or actually we often
don't use a checkerboard we used to like
to think of it as people standing in a
circle right so if all 10 billion people
are just standing out there in a big
circle where they're hundred people they
know are the ones right next to them in
the circle so they're I have 50 friends
on my left and 50 on my right and I
don't know anybody else and the same for
everybody else in the circle the same
thing that's a very big world because
for me to get a message let's say to
someone diametrically opposite me I have
to go leap frogging around in steps of
50 right and it's gonna take a long time
to get over five billion people away so
path length very long but clustering
very well it is clustering yeah high
clustering because of my 50 friends on
either side they will overlap a lot
right you know if I move as I moved to
my friends there so those worlds that
that kind of world has very high
clustering but very long paths yeah and
the other kind of world the random world
has very is very small but it has no
clustering right and so what we thought
was this kind of power
thing is that our wives it feels like
our lives are very clustered most of our
friends do know each other or at least
many of them do much more so than if the
world were random but yet the world
seems small almost as small as if it
were random right and so that wasn't
obvious how could you have both because
the real world somehow does have both
could you make a model that has both and
what Duncan and I realized but mainly
him was that what was really important I
mean one way to do it and we thought
this was the way it was probably done is
if people had certain number of
far-flung connections to give you an
example of what I'm talking about
I used to play a lot of chess on the
Internet and I got to be friends with a
guy in Holland and I mean I would say he
was really my friend I knew how many
kids he had and I knew about his life
and I never met him actually face to
face but I feel like he was my friend
but the point being if I wanted to get a
message to somebody in Holland I could
use my link to him
and there be a chance he would know that
person or he'd know someone who would
know the person in other words there was
this bridge where I was suddenly
connected to somebody I had no business
being connected to except that we both
like to play chess on the Internet and
that bridge not only made me closer to
everyone in Holland but everyone that I
know is also now much closer to everyone
in Holland although they don't realize
it right right because they me and I can
take the bridge you know what it means
likewise more conceptually if you had a
friend from high school who is now a
classical pianist suddenly you have a
whole bunch of connections it's a short
distance to you to everyone in the
classical music world exactly right and
and so what's interesting about this
mechanism we call that shortcuts is that
the shortcuts really make the world very
small very quickly though you don't
sense it because you don't realize
you're connected to everyone in the
classical music world I I mean because
it doesn't sort of operate in your
consciousness but you are and so this
this shortcut mechanism we showed that
very very few shortcuts were enough to
make the world incredibly small and
that seemed to be a very generic
phenomenon that because it took so few
of them it seemed like most networks
would have this property because you
kind of in order to avoid it you had to
scrupulously avoid having any shortcuts
oh yeah Network and so we made a
prediction back in well I guess it was
uh now I'm facing out one night when did
that paper come on mmm while ago yeah
over Surrey I think it was okay
ninety-eight yeah yeah that sounds right
yeah 1998 the paper came out in 1998 and
so we had set the brain for instance
will turn out to be a small world
network when we can measure all the
connections that we haven't yet measured
all the connections between all the
neurons
there's estimated to be trillions of
neurons in the brain tens of trillions I
think so we don't know what the
connectome as they call it is my brain
but we do know the connectome of a tiny
worm that's the one nervous system
that's been completely mapped out called
C elegans oh yeah my favorite little
tiny worm yeah so we know every neuron
in its body there's about 300 of them
it's only a few I sent something like on
the order of a thousand cells in the
whole creature but by looking at the
nervous system of this worm we showed
that it actually satisfied our criteria
for a small world that it was much more
clustered than a random world yeah but
it also had path length about comparable
to a random world so is as small as it
could be while much more clustered and
the internet and a whole bunch of other
networks in the real world other
networks lots of real world networks
turned and since then I mean in the
twenty years since then it's been
abundantly documented that that our
prediction was right lots of naturally
occurring networks will be small worlds
and you could ask well okay so what but
what's interesting is that small worlds
allow for very fast propagation of
information through these shortcuts so
anything that needs to coordinate itself
or act as a coordinated unit but is very
big a small world mechanism is a really
good way to do it but also it's
dangerous in the case of like the HIV
example anything that can spread for
good or for bad we'll spread much faster
on a small world than it would on on say
on the lattice or a ring and also
typically a wonderful example of
self-organization right like nobody
planed it out you said
naturally-occurring
these there's mechanisms that typically
give rise to networks just like this
mmm-hmm right they're found all over the
place
and as you say there's no central
planner there's no need to design it it
just sort of happens on its own I did
want to mention one thing earlier
actually that I sort of I had in my head
but didn't say out loud which was that
there's another way of making the world
small that you could imagine which we
deliberately did not imagine which is
you could imagine that there's somebody
that everybody knows right I mean if
everybody knows Louis Weisberg right so
I use that example because Malcolm
Gladwell wrote an article a long time
ago called six degrees of Louis Weisberg
that she was this person in in Chicago
that seemed to know jazz musicians and
she knew newspaper people and just
everybody knew Louis Weisberg anyway so
that's one way that the world can be
small if everyone knows these super hubs
these connectors right then of course
everyone's just a few degrees away
because they're all close to Louis
Weisberg but we didn't think that was
really gonna be first of all that felt
like cheating like of course that will
make the world small if you have that
but more to the point we thought that's
not really gonna be how nature will use
it but that's not the mechanism because
for one thing it's hard for the Louis
Weisberg out there to maintain all those
connections it's a lot of energetic cost
a lot of it's just hard and you know he
needed to write well you don't need it I
mean of course you might have it but but
it you don't need it the shortcut
mechanism and you need only very few of
those doesn't cost much and that that
will do the job for you but so we
deliberately ignored also I I would say
that I had been told by my friends in
neuroscience that every neuron in the
brain connects to about that is makes
synapses with about 10,000 others okay
it might sound like a lot but then when
you remember that there's you know
trillion neurons in the brain or
something like that or maybe it's a
hundred billion but it's it's way way
too yeah but it's a lot yeah okay right
so it's on order of a hundred billion so
that's right so if it's ten to the
eleventh
but there's only ten to the four
synapses per neuron yeah your dad you
know that's a factor of 10 to the
seventh different so it's a very sparse
network in that sense you're not
connected to anything like the whole
network and there are no lowest
Weisberg's in the brain so we we
deliberately didn't want to pay
attention to those networks and the
reason I'm harping on this is because we
missed the boat it turns out that there
are a lot of networks that use hubs the
most obvious being airports you know if
you think for the airport the airport
system and you for air travel you fly to
a hub and the hub has a lot of roots
going into it so there are some networks
that use this hub mechanism to make the
world small and so that was studied by
other people and we didn't you know like
I say it's an interesting thing like in
the history of science that sometimes
you'll have a prejudice about what you
think the way the world should be and
you deliberately don't let yourself
entertain another possibility because it
strikes you as ugly or too simple or
irritating in some way the world is very
irritating because they keeps doing
different things into in circumstances
and different model unemployment but
still I could civil bothers him
sometimes anyway those kinds of networks
with the hub's were published you know
an analysis of them came out the year
after our paper on the small world Rekha
Albert and her advisor laszlo barabasi
wrote a paper about what they called
scale-free networks that had not only
hubs but also a distribution of the
jargon is degree that's how many
connections any individual node has how
many friends in our earlier social
network analogy so if you ask how many
people have say 10 friends how many have
a hundred friends how many have a
thousand friends you can find people
with more or less big rolodexes um and
it obeyed a power law in that you know
there was the probability of having a
certain number of friends
went down like the number of friends to
some power one over it was an inverse
you know like one over X to some power
we're close to three or so one point two
so that technically he point it would be
a small world network but it has this
extra feature that they're also Louis
Weisberg's
there were Louis Weisberg's and also
sort of like things a little bit less
than Louis Weisberg you had sort of
Louis Weisberg's at all scales of degree
they were small worlds they didn't have
the right clustering properties actually
at least in the first models so we
missed the hubs but Baba she and Albert
missed the clustering and since then
people have you know figured out that
real networks have are more complicated
than the models either of us proposed
which was no surprise we were both
putting out really idealized simple
models and do you think for thought
experiments because this is within the
realm of self-organization I mean these
kind of networks we can speculate a
little bit it's late in the podcast
these are at the heart of how complexity
and complicated interconnected systems
arise in a world that is ultimately
governed by the second law of
thermodynamics and things run down well
huh well it's all I can say is that both
of these are common Network themes the
small world theme and the scale-free
there there are a lot of other things
going on we've we've learned a lot more
about networks in the past twenty years
so they were they were very stimulating
early ideas I think we could say that I
wouldn't I wouldn't claim that either
one of them is in kind of I mean small
world law is pretty much a universal law
that almost every real-world network is
going to be a small world by our
criteria yeah scale-free has not held up
as well but it's still a pretty common
theme to say if you the power law part
is the part that's not reliable if you
just ask is the distribution of degrees
something that obeys a heavy tail
meaning it doesn't look like a
bell-shaped curve with a exponentially
damped tail but it has something that's
got a lot of a lot more of these Louis
Weisberg's than you would think yeah
that does seem to be true yeah a heavy
tail distribution has a lot more things
you might think are unlikely or
improbable then you would get by doing
sort of
bell curve like probability distribution
that's right and the other work so the
world is full of things like that and
we're still learning to deal with that
maybe you know earthquakes or solar
flares are examples of these which means
that you know terrible disasters can
happen a lot more frequently than we
might guess uh-huh it's true there are a
lot of those heavy tailed distributions
in natural disasters yeah with floods
wildfires yeah I mean the statistics of
those are often very heavy tailed so
okay clearly we have enough room for a
whole other podcast down the line so
that is good but I do want to give you
the chance because you mentioned right
at the beginning how the very favorite
tool of every mathematician which is
calculus isn't an obvious fit to the
kinds of studies you want to do with the
fireflies where there seem to be some
kind of discontinuous jump and
nevertheless your most recent book is
about calculus so I think many people
think of calculus says there's nothing
new there like we've done calculus a
long time ago and in fact memory of it
is you know one might say a terrible
class I had in high school what is it
that you think makes us need another
book about calculus right now hahaha
well I would sing the praises of
calculus I think it's one of the
greatest achievements in the history of
humanity you know this is something that
took about more than 2,000 years to
develop starting from the days of
Archimedes up through isaac newton and
leibniz and i'm taking a very broad view
of what I mean by calculus but let's say
roughly speaking the systematic use of
infinity to solve hard problems I you
know that's the thrilling idea in
calculus that you can take a hard
problem and chop it up into infinitely
small that is infinitely many
infinitesimally small pieces and then
those turn out to be easier problems to
solve those small ones and then if you
can figure out a way to put them back
together which is what we call integral
calculus or integrating a differential
equation then you can do the kind of
math that has changed the world I mean
that's the math that let Maxwell predict
the phenomenon of wireless that's
letting us talk to each other right now
yeah I always
I to gloss calculus as saying is the
statement that a medium-sized thing can
be thought of as an infinite number of
infinitely small things yeah that's a
great great insight and it it literally
changed the world we can't without it we
wouldn't have radio we wouldn't have
television we wouldn't have turned the
tide in the fight against HIV so in the
book I'm trying to make it's called
infinite powers and I'm trying to make
the case about just how how
revolutionary calculus was when it was
invented and how it's still giving us
gifts today but I feel that there's a
need to do it while it's true as you say
it's not the newest thing under the Sun
a lot of people in fact like million
more than a million students in the US
alone take calculus every year and for
them it's something that they do the
advanced placement test and they don't
know what the heck they you know why did
I do that yeah
it's often just taught as like a lot of
there's a lot to learn I mean there's a
lot of technical things to learn about
how to do this kind of integral or that
kind of derivative but I feel like the
great human story of this fantastic idea
that I would rank right up there with
evolution and quantum theory you know
this is a fantastic thing that I want
people to understand just how rich the
story is and and how world-changing it
was and still is yeah that's that's why
I add some to me it's not another
calculus book it's a book that's we know
it those of us who are professional
scientists know these things but I don't
think that the typical high school
student or even someone who might be
teaching it in high school they may not
realize this this very broad context of
what calculus has done for the world
well Jennifer wrote a book about
calculus called the calculus Diaries and
the gimmick was that a 40-something year
old English major learns calculus and
learns to apply it to the world so I was
helpful as you know an experimental test
subject when we went to Vegas or drove a
car and and just noticed all the
different ways in which you could think
about the phenomena using calculus so I
completely agree with you that people
just don't quite appreciate how
absolutely universal it is and if you
really get what calculus is trying to
tell you your view of the world changes
in a profound way perfect
right exactly so I feel like that that
needs to be better known that this
shouldn't just be for insiders you know
I really I feel it's a beautiful thing
it's an inspiring thing and so I know
there are people out there who would who
would like to know this I'm I should say
I've written the book for this sort of
person actually that you and I both like
to write for the educated person who's
curious but who is not a professional
physicist or mathematician or may not
have even taken these subjects in
college maybe was happy to be done with
them in high school yeah well I think
that's what makes it interesting because
we probably there's a pre-existing
resonance with the word calculus in many
people's minds and it won't always be
positive so you're you don't have a
blank slate to deal with you're trying
to push up against some resistance and
and that's a fun challenge to take up
yes it is yep all right to see the story
guys thanks so much for your time Thank
You Sean this is great fun I'll
definitely be recommending all your
books and I want to read more about
small worlds and scale-free networks and
things like that and maybe we'll have
you on the podcast again to dig into
them further okay my pleasure I hope I
will alright thanks a lot
[Music]
you